I'll just here for the ride in the honey
bones thank you for the honey buns baby
icing frost frost abun just playing my
life and I was all dude I probably ate
five ramen noodle soups a day when you
got out or when I was in there the whole
time like I probably ate 5 ramen noodle
soups a day like at least two honey buns
just eating total [ __ ] and you were
still in the best shape yeah it's it's
it's [ __ ] nuts man I remember when he
got out on work release and like we were
trying to work out together and he's
like smoking cigarettes drinking instant
coffee and like eating like doing
push-ups with my mom on his back
[ __ ] keep up you guys were
trying to work out together when you got
out no you were working out together how
did that go hey man you work where we
used to bond where where were you
working out at oh his uh that place
fusion he was living at and seen Pete
before that was it yeah house at the
house oh yeah dad's house okay so you
guys were working out like in the
driveway or something it was like
working at the driveway like he was
showing me like what they used to do
like to pass the time and work out it
was just like all squats push-ups yeah
and just like lifting random [ __ ] like
all the different kinds of push-ups I
always thought we're like really
interesting because you know you got
like your basic ones yeah you got the
ones like where you crawl and then it's
like okay we're gonna crawl all the way
down the driveway and then do push-ups
and then you just like kind of doing
this army crawl the whole time you're
smoking dipping and drinking instant
coffee oh yeah dude I would be on the
REC yard doing on the pull-up bar with a
mouthful of skull into like a top roll
up cigarette smoking it doing pull-ups I
mean that's how you had add resistance
yeah yeah didn't you say at one point
they banned cigarettes yeah they they
they took the cigarettes out I forget
what year that was but they gave us a
year notice and so we're like oh it's a
year but then that [ __ ] went by so fast
it was like October one year and then we
saw like Flyers everywhere it was like
wait what it's like that's pretty much
all you have and you know II mean right
a little bit of freedom yeah yeah so
they were gonna ban it the next October
that year but there were two stops um
the September before so like the whole
year goes by and then at the end
everybody's [ __ ] scrambling everyone's
I get burying them on the [ __ ] yard
so they stop selling them and then I
mean the price of a five dollar packet
top went up to like 200 I've just kept
doubling like it went to 10 then 20 then
40 and then it got all the way up to
like 250 bucks I heard some of the
reception centers people first come in
yeah they were going for like five six
hundred dollars for one [ __ ] like
small a spike atop Wow so that was that
made it easy to quit smoking yeah I
don't like smoking [ __ ] $40 like pin
joints of locators now what about it
what about we finally got out like what
was it like Oh like leading up how is
that I was at work release oh okay this
is no yes go to a camp after that or why
I went to work release at the Largo
goodwills right cross street from
diamond dollz on 19 yeah but before I
got there that celebration station it is
at right there yeah it's closer they're
not that close not close enough I go to
this I go to the goodwill it shut down
now but I went there but before I got
there there was a [ __ ] that
raped some chick at [ __ ] diamond
dollz that was out there and then
another guy killed it was at least one
or two people and then set the house on
fire damn that was at work release I
mean work release is you have less than
a [ __ ] year left right right and what
do they make you do for work you're like
a halfway house or no I mean it's or
they just take you in it's pretty much
like a halfway house but it's still do
see it's not like it's not like an
actual prison okay it's like super-low
custody there's a lot but you don't have
that much [ __ ] time left and these
[ __ ] stupid [ __ ] did like the
dumbest [ __ ] and I don't know they
it was that whole thing I like doing
that much time like that was the first
time like me really doing time so being
that gone that long I'm like I can
definitely wait now I'm good to go do
like all this dumb [ __ ] you know yeah
when you rode your bike like how far to
go I work two jobs so I would leave this
Center at like 5:00 in the morning and
ride my bike from there to Indian Rocks
Beach home every day so I was doing like
I was doing like 22 miles a day but I
would leave the centre-left five here
was the center the center was right
cross street from diamond dollz on
that's far as [ __ ] bike ride ride I
don't even drive that far on midnight 11
o'clock or midnight and I think it was
11 ride to get back because that was
like our curfew so I'm then I would get
like 2 hours of sleep and I would just
keep doing it but I was so [ __ ]
pumped just to be able to just write
you're feeling a little bit of freedom
and [ __ ] right that's riding my bike
working and just kind of feeling normal
you know what I mean yeah yeah just kind
of being like a normal person in the
world yes well not really normal but
right yeah but you're not in prison
anymore I'm riding a bike with you
that's like the people on the bus and
take a bus in Florida you're like God
he's a [ __ ] drug normal but down here
you just you look down at everybody
that's yeah you see somebody walking on
the side of like DUI definitely I mean I
love that but so but that [ __ ] came to
they after those guys did that [ __ ] I
remember one morning woke up in like
3:00 in the morning all that like it was
like the was like the riot squad I
forgot the [ __ ] their name was in there
for prison they all came in all of our
doors said all right [ __ ] pack
your [ __ ] you're going back to prison
looks like no God so I had to go back to
one of the that reception camp I first
went to
[Laughter]